oh my god pick a child hey cute and lazy
Pokemon
I
oh no humans were genetically
predisposed ition to want to catch them
all it's part of our basic instincts
food water pokémons shelter it was only
natural that Pokemon go would be such a
huge hit it's just a bummer that it
doesn't work constant crashes the server
is being down bugs like gym leaders
being invincible you know what I'm
talking about these things suck and
they're ridiculously consistent but
that's not even the main issue here
mechanically and thematically this isn't
very Pokemon Pokemon go is about
catching as many pokemon is humanly
possible then taking the weaker ones and
turning them into candy to make the
strong ones even stronger think about it
if your favorite Pokemon is an EV you're
supposed to capture as many V's as you
can and turn them into EV candy and
force feed them to your EV to make it a
powerhouse it's like Pokemon Floyd Gras
gyms are supposed to be strategic a
rock-paper-scissors type mechanic where
your trainer chooses the best pokemon
for the given situation you have to use
your pokedex to learn about other
Pokemon even if you don't own them that
knowledge helps you know their strengths
and their weaknesses in Pokemon go
you're just pumping more and more candy
and Stardust meth into them to get a
higher CP it's taking away the intrigue
in the curiosity of the world it's
distilling it to a simple number but the
concept the idea of catching things
learning about them and sharing them
with the world is so good that's what
the original creator of pokemon Satoshi
Tajiri envisioned right from the start
let's take a trip down memory lane
Tajiri grew up in Tokyo in the late
1960s and he was really into bugs I mean
like really into them he was actually
nicknamed mr. bug by his classmates
Tajiri was inspired to make games that
gave children the feeling of catching
and collecting interesting creatures
just like he did this is why the
starting area of the original games are
bug areas this is why in the Japanese
version of the game and animated series
ashes name is
satoshi Satoshi is ash and he wanted us
to feel the same passion he felled
that's why in the animated series
there's sincere moments like when ash
chooses his pokemons happiness over his
own or why his pokemon fight past the
point where they should for him ash
learns to be more patient that knowledge
is power kindness for other beings
there's more this game than just
catching and while I'm on this subject
you know in every series there's a rival
trainer who's kind of a jerk and doesn't
care about his Pokemon he pushes them
really hard and doesn't form a bond well
Pokemon go is kind of forcing players
into that role that's right you're Gary
you can never have too many pokemon
that's my motto now to be fair Pokemon
go does get kids to go outside and catch
bugs in fact it's probably the best
iteration of the game as far as getting
people out and moving and passionate
about these fascinating creatures all
around us I'm truly glad Pokemon go
exists because it got a whole world
fascinated about Pokemon but it's just
the bare minimum version of it despite
what people may think the best part of
pokemon isn't the hunt it's the interest
the nurturing and the sharing of these
creatures that makes it truly special
hopefully down the road we get a game
that truly exemplifies what pokemon is
all about